[Applaudissements]
chers amis c'est un plaisir pour moi élu
de l'outre ma de prendre la parole ce
matin devant
vous merci monsieur le Président cher
Nicolas sarzi de m'avoir accordé votre
confiance en mars 2014 cont tous les
pronostique je reprends à la gauche la
ville de Saint-Paul une commune de 10
habitant cette victoire a été possible
grâce à l'Union de la Droite dont j'ai
été l'un des prépaux artisant à la
Réunion elle nous a permis de conserver
le Conseil départemental en mars dernier
en 2010 déjà face à une Go divisée elle
nous ouvrait les portes du conseil
régional et j'en suis persuadé cette
solide plateforme UNP auj républicain
IDI objectif Ron per permettra à la
droite de conserver la région avec à sa
tête Didier Robert qui accompit un
excellent travail pour la Réunion oui
tous ensemble ili nous le pouvons vive
la France vive la République vive la
répu vive la France vive la république
républainz une dynamique à la
franceè merci beaucoup vous vous
rappelez mes chers amis